so
those that did not join us in person
will be able to review
afterwards so i wanted to start by
asking all of you about the progress
that you have made since last time
so how many of you have joined the
previous session
what do you mean
uh the previous session that we had for
this program
you talking about were we in attendance
oh yeah yeah just a few were present in
the previous session oh okay
i was present all right perfect thank
you
and juliana is saying that she wasn't
lying were you there also
okay okay so great
last time i asked everyone to try and
yeah go ahead yeah this is nyam um yeah
but
i was uh you know when he was uh i was
joining that class and i was following
you
uh how to do the pipeline but i thought
i will do later
but i i was waiting for the you posted
the recording but
i never found that so i could not finish
that pipeline
okay well that's fine i'm sorry about
the recording i did not
remember to record it on time so this
time we'll try and do
the pipeline together and
also i did want to ask all of you
if you have updated your profile
so i know that when in hands
were you able to update your profile
yeah i updated what else need i i think
i'm fine
okay and juliana were you able to log
into omix live you can update your
profile
um i believe so
i'm trying to log into it right now
wi-fi at my school
is being really um terrible
got it okay so
let me just briefly show you how to do
that
and i see we have dr bashir
join us as well so i just wanted to make
sure that everybody from last time was
able to log in successfully
so we want to make sure that everybody's
profile is updated
how do you get there that's question
number one so the way you get there is
once you're logged in
you go right here and it will show you
your profile
plus your activity and the courses that
you're enrolled in
as well as the programs that you're
involved
in and if you are going to be working on
an independent project
that project is going to be here and
then here you will have all of your
certification
so as you make progress
in this whole program the objective is
really to
look at some examples of projects that
others have done
and tried to do that yes diane did you
want to say something
okay so the objective is really to go
through some examples of projects that
we have to learn about
how to do the analysis independently and
most of the steps are actually recorded
there in a
fairly detailed way so if you lose track
of where we are and what we're trying to
do you can always go back there
the other thing that you might want to
kind of keep track of
is on the page
you will find the information about
upcoming sessions and uh
the previous recordings and things like
that so really
this is a way to keep track of the links
for the sessions and also
there is below here a
way to ask a question so this is for
slack have all of you join slack
i have all right perfect
and nayan were you able to join slack
mr yeah
okay okay
perfect and uh okay thank you anin and
what about dr bashir were you able to
join slack as well
i wasn't i'm sorry i wasn't follow
this part so
do you mind if you will go back i'm
sorry
yeah so i was just asking there's the
link i'm gonna post it right here
on um the chat
you can create an account if you don't
have an account yet
or down at the bottom of the program
page if you scroll all the way down
this is a button that will lead you to
the slide channel
and so on the slack channel you'll be
able to ask technical
questions if you have any as you're
going through the pipelines or whatever
analysis that we're doing if you have
any questions
feel free to post it here i'll try and
keep everything updated here as well you
can see here invitations to the zoom
meeting
or recordings of the previous session or
any kind of reference articles
especially for things that we discuss in
the in the session
if you have any questions or if you want
additional information
and i have those articles i'll be
posting them here as well
okay so last time
we spoke about multiple sequence
alignments
and we even went uh to find some data
and try to analyze that data together
and so i wanted to start from there
so that we can repeat some of the things
that we did
and there's actually two different
things that we did last time so we
looked at
where does this data come from so what
are some of the
different data types and what are some
of the different ways that we can
analyze that data just kind of getting
an overview
and then we looked at some specific
examples based on
multiple sequence alignments and based
on consensus sequences as opposed to
reads that were generated but did not
map onto the reference genome so
to do that i want to
start with a brief
example so we'll go to
the platform and hopefully this will
refresh everyone's memory on
where we were so the first thing that we
tried to do was to take an example
from in a project and sf9
project and that project is
data that was stored in fastq files
and the way we can get uh fast q
files to understand what's in them is we
need to
map those fastq files that contain short
reads
onto a reference genome and to do that
we looked at this example
where we took several different steps
from loading the data
and then to map
this data onto the reference genome
or we also could include
trimming the data before that and then
performing pcr clean and then
we can do the same right so the
objective of that pipeline was to
generate
unmapped reads has anyone taken a look
at the sf9 project
already and try to replicate that
okay so just so that you know how to
follow the same steps
i want to recommend for all of you to go
in to the courses tab
and find a project that you can follow
along
called sf9
okay so this one project 8 spot obtainer
for lupera
it really tells you how to run this
pipeline and to
then map the non-mapped reads
onto a new genome to understand
uh what could be found inside those
reads so that was example number one
that we did example number two that we
did
was uh an example from phylogenetic
analysis so how to do multiple sequence
alignment
and then using mathematical model or a
statistical model
for inference of relationships between
sequences
of viruses and so that was right here
under the phylogenetic tree
and we looked at ebola virus or
oscilloscope
ii either one what we are essentially
doing in this pipeline
is we are looking at sequence similarity
based on nucleotide similarity or based
on amino acid sequence
similarity and then using
the nucleotides as tri codons or
trinucleotide codons that encode for
amino acids
to understand how they could be
evolutionary related to each other so
how many of you remember this pipeline
that we did last time
okay so um if any of you have
tried doing this last time or maybe even
before that you were familiar with
multiple sequence alignment
should be familiar uh has anyone
previously done
sequence alignment here
yeah okay so
uh when you remember doing this from
last time right
yes okay and nyan also
uh remembers this or has done it before
and uh juliana
do you remember this from last time yes
sir
okay and uh dr bashir it's okay if you
don't remember
no it's fine i i believe we did it last
time it's fine for me
okay okay yeah but uh today i just have
uh some allergies so it's fine
uh yeah i i will do my best to follow
with you
so this was an example without
any real data right all we wanted to
understand here was conceptually how to
go
from loading the data then performing
multiple sequence alignment
then this is a phylogenetic analysis
using
these multiple different types of
algorithms
and then we looked at the consensus tree
between all of them to understand what
is the relationship between the
sequences
based on sequence similarity and based
on the molecular clock
so now let's take this and we will
actually find the data ourselves and
instead of
building this pipeline from a demo
we will try to upload our own data and
see
how that works so uh
first of all what kind of data are we
using for this phylogenetic analysis
does someone
remember what type of files are we
looking for
is it faster files yep
perfect so fast files as you remember
contain nucleotide sequences and
that will be typically a whole genome or
some portion of a genome that is
called a consensus genome so to find
some of this data
let's go to ncbi virus
and we'll try to find some data here
that we can use today in our analysis
so an ncbi virus
let me know once you're there so we can
move on
okay you can put something uh okay
thank you dr beshear
you're locked out of your account what
what does that mean julian
i tried to log in and it said that my
access has been temporarily
um i guess like paused or something
from the site creator
oh wait let me try something else i have
a better idea
okay uh have you been able to log in
to or you don't have to log in were you
able to navigate to ncbi virus
yeah i can do that i was trying i was
talking about my other account but we
can talk about that
after okay okay so
here we want to find some sequences that
we can analyze so remember that we
can search by virus and so let's take
an example from source code two viruses
uh if we type in source
right here and just wait a couple of
seconds it should pop
up okay so here you can see
different uh viruses
that are bats or other coronaviruses but
we want to go for this
severe acute respiratory syndrome
coronavirus ii
so if you click on that it should take
you to the page
with all of these sequences okay so let
me know once you're here
okay so if you did manage to get here
you will find here different types of
filters
on the left side and so
we can select based on accession id
so type in the specific ids that we're
interested in
we can do sequence links whether it's
the full genome
who knows how long is the source code 2
gene or
approximately
what keyword use for the source
what's it what's it 150
the link sequence link
right that was probably for reads 150 oh
okay okay
the genome length is about 30 000
nucleotides
what's keyword use for the source
so if you go back and you just start
from
search by virus what you do is
there's a search field right here and
you just type in
source and you can wait a few seconds
and it will appear in the drop down
and then i use this source code too
do you see the same thing man yeah
yeah okay and so once you click there
it pulls up all of the available
sequences which is 842
166. so
here as i mentioned you can search by
or filter by accession sequence links
and all kinds of
additional things that you can find and
what's interesting is that they've
recently
added here the pango lineage
and so you can search here for the
different types of
lineages that you probably are familiar
with
um and here's the uk
variant for example or the uk pangolin
page
so you can search here by bengal lineage
you can also look over here by host as
you remember there's a human
bat penguin so here for example you can
search for penguins
um yeah actually
the penguin i forget the scientific name
for penguin but let's try that
also well
we have to look it up unfortunately they
did not do it
is that easy to find but
we will look for human
okay so now let's try to
think of a meaningful comparison
to build our phylogenetic tree
what do you think might be an
interesting way to study these sequences
and ask some kind of a research question
about differences
in nucleotide sequences
any suggestions any ideas
um could we see if they are
all uh i guess
geographically uh aligned or
in some type of uh specific area
or you know or in other animals
i don't know okay okay so
geographic location so we can search for
different countries
for example we can look for geographic
region right here and we can say why
don't we find let's say
louisiana which would be
in america
here you can search for la
and maybe we can compare that
to
[Music]
um
usa la
and we're checking out another one
so let's say
california
okay
now we have at least several different
types of filters that we can do we said
already
we can do the host human different
animals
we can do location but probably a time
component is also important here
beginning the pandemic
the end of the pandemic in the middle
somewhere so to give it some contrast
we might want to find some additional
filtering here by collection date
so collection date and we can say
let's say the 30th
of december
or let's say 19.
okay so already 12
2019
maybe okay maybe they don't have it from
there so let's do it
0 2 20 20.
is that a validate
let's find 20 20.
january first
okay two let's say
from 2020
and we'll take something in
the end
okay so here we have multiple so
7 000 nucleotides we've selected
different characteristics maybe we
should make sure
that we also search for
genome completeness
nucleotide completeness and we'll just
take the complete ones
so now we should have 5161 genomes to
select from
does everyone have the same number
idea all right
yes okay
um doctor elliot we supposed to do it in
the same time with you or
after you will finish it but i'm
confused
i think it would be better to do it at
the same time that way we can start the
pipeline and you will have your own
individual pipeline and you will be able
to do it on your own
maybe your ideas about what exactly you
want to analyze will change
and so by next time you can actually
have a pipeline running
okay and nayan were you able to find all
of these filters
no i'm trying
do you want us to wait or should we go
on
i can do later when i finish the lecture
okay well today we wanted to do some
hands-on so that everybody can try
and follow along but you can also review
this afterwards so
we have here now over 5000 so let's
select some interesting ones
that might be useful for our analysis
so again we have here also sorting
by different types and it's kind of
difficult to use this interface
to actually select the ones that we
would like to analyze
so instead what we can do is we can
uh go right here
and we can download this
okay so here if you click on download
here on top
you can select what exactly do we want
to
download and i think what we want to
start with is just take this csv format
and download a table so i'll download
all records
next and here i will have different
types of information that i can include
in the
actual table so i'll just download as it
is suggesting
and once i have this file i can open it
in excel
and select the specific ones that i
would like to compare
so i'm going to open this in excel
okay and so now i can filter them
more easily and select the ones that i'm
interested in
so i have here collection date and i
want to select something that will give
me a contrast so i want to first of all
select maybe something that is early on
and then something that is later from
two sites remember i had
louisiana and california and so here i
have
uh from california and here i have some
from louisiana but i have a lot of them
so what i will first do is i will create
a filter
and i will just select one of them so
let's just select from california first
once i've selected these let's select
some early ones
and i can just sort them by ascending
and so i see this is the first month
right so this is in january
and then february etc and so maybe i
should take
january february march
so i'll have three and maybe from each
one
from each one of our from
each one of our
selections we'll take a look at the
pangolin
clade right and we will take a look here
so that we select some uniform one so i
see here that in the beginning
remember that it started splitting up
from a to b
to c etc and so here you can start
selecting maybe let's take just the a
ones
so this is in january so i'm going to
create right here i'm going to just take
this whole
section and then i will take
another one from a so this is in
february
and here's another one in february this
is in march
so i'll take these are all for march
and i'm just going to put them right
here
and here i'll just copy this header
and put it inside now since some of you
are following along do let me know if
you want me to slow down and explain
what i'm doing
if you just want to follow along later
that's also fine but i'm just creating
here
a collection of specific ones
that i will select for my analysis
so i took some from california now let
me find some from
louisiana
in louisiana it seems like i need to
again do assembly
the earliest one i see is in march
so why don't we take the ones
again do we have any a's yes so we have
some a so i have some a
and then i have another one a in march
and another one right here also in march
so i will take these
for the early ones
so i can even mark them here so these
are
california
early
and these are louisiana early
and i will take the late ones so first
of all let's go to louisiana
late ones so here i have the end of 2020
and now i will be sure to take the ones
that
are b's for sure but also as it goes
into the b it starts splitting up even
more
and so i can see that 1.1 or 1.2
1.5 so these are the later ones so why
don't we take also something consistent
so we will take here the ones from
the 11th month and so let's take
if we take b12 it seems like we have
b12 b12 so we have quite a number of b
one two and also we have b one five nine
six
1596 okay so
1595. okay so we have a few of these as
well
so let's try to take one five nine
six okay so here's one
and one five nine six here's another one
and here's another one
so these are going to be louisiana late
and now let's do the same thing for
california
okay so here we have
okay so yeah so here we have
um b1296 okay so this doesn't have
596 so we can choose something else that
is also consistent here so it looks like
we have
one three one one a lot five
nine three six eight okay so let's see
what else do we have
here so it's eleventh month you can see
that the number of sequences
is starting to grow very fast
five main six we don't have so why don't
we go do we have five
one two okay so here we have the
eleventh month
the eleventh
okay and then here we have 12 so right
there
one two let's prime from the tenth
okay right here okay now
what we need from here is to just select
these accession ids to be able to find
them
the actual sequences right so this is
going to be californialy
and what i want to do is i want to make
sure that i save this table so that
whenever i want to go back
and see where did this actually come
from i will be able to annotate my
information from here so i will take
and i will save this
and save it like this and call it
so i can easily find it so now i want to
take these accession numbers
and it's easy to go back to the
interface
that we were in and remember
i have all kinds of filters here right
so where would i use these ids to filter
out
and find the specific genomes that i'm
looking for
what do you think
anyone
is everyone still there
yeah yeah we are here but i'm slightly
late i'm
trying to do different places and uh
i did like the sequence length uh
is really from a thousand to like
uh um like 20
but it didn't work so first i tried to
compare egypt to the netherlands instead
of
louisiana to california um
yeah but yeah but i'm sure so but i'm
late i'm late because you are
really you are speaking too fast but
it's fine
i can go back to the video i can
practice again so
yeah don't never mind about just uh
like for being late for me no that's
fine but
i do want to mention that if you can see
the total length of the
genome is about 30 000 nucleotides
so whenever you're selecting the range
of links try to make it either the
complete one which is going to be
close to 30 000 or if you're looking
some of them
are sequences of individual genes and so
those could be for example
1000 or 2000 or something like this
and even shorter so the minimum the
minimum should be
the the average of the the length
correct
like 30 000 this is a minimum or the
maximum
right well this is the question i think
more dependent on what your question is
do you want to find
what's called overall global
sequence similarity i i'm trying to see
like
similar the the strains in egypt versus
like netherlands the holland uh because
i am egyptian and i
got my phd from holland so uh this is
why i'm trying to see that
i'm curious to know and also i'm from
louisiana i'm more in louisiana right
now
so um well what would make sense
is to think about do you want to find
similarities in the full genome
or just in a portion like the spike
protein which one would be more
interesting to you
um initially i can just the full genome
as initial step and if i find
similarities i will see
another like the portion of the genome
itself
so the language so then you should just
go
instead of right so instead of going for
sequence links
go under refseq genome completeness
which means that it is the complete
genome and select here complete
i do not have the option for the
complete in this and my
and my uh website over here i don't know
why
uh i tried to see that i did
yeah go ahead and now here nucleotide
completeness
and now complete i have partial i do not
have the complete
the problem probably because you already
have sequence length maybe remove your
filter for sequence length
this is before doing the sequence length
uh this is before doing it
uh so let me let me to i will start from
the beginning from the
link and uh yeah we can
because today is a practice day so if
you don't mind i can share my
my slides if you don't mind you can
share your screen
while the other question yellow let's
let's try that real quick and
and for everyone if you also have
similar challenges do let me know let me
just try here yeah go ahead do you want
to share your screen
actually i cannot i cannot start screen
share while other
participant is sharing so it seems
actually
you need to make it like uh multiple uh
participants
i think you should be able to share now
okay
okay so i'm here already
so this is the oh yeah i see it right
now okay complete
okay i didn't see it before okay so
if i if i will go to share like
compare region uh like uh
africa uh sorry not africa all
the africa uh i will take like egypt
egypt and
versus uh netherlands
the netherlands
okay and
so you said actually i if i would like
to
make like the whole genome so that uh
go to like this is uh completely correct
yeah yeah this is correct yeah and they
can ignore the
uh sequence uh length yeah
okay and yeah you're on the right track
right so now think about
what maybe the dates uh yeah you know
you are comparing from the same date you
might want to say i want to just
select one month and compare it within
that month
within one month i i did one year so
this is maybe it's my mistake
if i will i mean remember this is a
virus so it is replicating fast
and it is acquiring mutations probably
every month there are some new mutations
so that's why it makes sense to make it
more specific
so let me uh from uh
try to well yeah you you go on with that
but i will just show you
maybe right so here
again let me just kind of remind you how
did we
use this it's a little bit difficult to
just use
this so instead once you've made your
preliminary selection you can go into
download and instead of downloading the
nucleotide sequences
just download the table and then
filtering it
in excel would be much easier so once
you have
your filtering what you can take are
just the accession ids
okay and then i can reset
all of these filters and just go into
accessions okay and now
i have you see 12 nucleotide sequences
and these are 12 that i selected from
here so i know exactly what they are
but i don't have to mess with all the
filters
okay okay yeah you know that's i'm it's
very interested in reality um
it's good and also the the best
uh part is it's it's game actually at
the summer time
so we have enough time to practice and
to play around
to mainly also i need to see like the
because for my knowledge the strains in
new york actually was the most like
aggressive ones
compared to the other states in
louisiana so also i'm curious to know
what kind of strains like they were in
new york because the mortality rate in
new york was the highest in
america in the beginning of the pandemic
of course yeah
right so and then we'll talk about what
kinds of changes these are and
especially trying to understand whether
it was the genomic mutations or maybe it
was just the population
density uh other comorbidities you know
there are multiple factors that could be
involved but
let's try to continue on uh
so with others nayan
juliana and juanine you guys have your
set of sequences
or would you like me to share what i got
uh you can share what you have cause i
stopped a while back
and just tried to keep up with you
okay so here is here are the accession
ids and what i did was i went to the
accessions right here
and press on plus and just paste them in
here
submit and now you have
12 sequences
so juliana and nayan
let me let me know if this is uh working
out for you
yes looking good
all right great all right so now we need
to download the actual fasta files
remember we want to download the pasta
files
so here we have sequence data faster
format
and we want to take the nucleotide
sequences
so just click on next and
download all records and you
you can use the default one so just
click on download
and let's download and actually look at
this data type
so these are
2 la california
or louisiana california early
late and
if you open this up how do you open a
fasta file a fasta file is just like a
text file so you can just click and open
with
any kind of a text editor you can
actually
see what's inside
okay so let me know were you able to
open it up on your computer and in the
meantime
what i wanted to show is that this is
the
accession id right so if i go back to my
table
that right there is going to be the
accession id
and then you can see that it has an
annotation
so it actually tells me where it was
from
and it looks like this was sequenced by
lsu and so
in louisiana right and it's a complete
genome and it was in 2020.
so you have some kind of a name here as
well and this is the full sequence
so as you can see it's not annotated
it's not broken up into anything
it just goes on completely until we have
the next one and if you have a find
function what you should
for me it's a command f if i just search
for
this symbol i should be able to see that
there are 12
of them and that tells me that there are
12 genomic sequences
in this file
okay so now the next step that we want
to do is we want to
build a phylogenetic tree now we can
build
a very simple phylogenetic tree
remember we did this last time so here
we have
selection of our nucleotides and the
first step that we can do is we can
align them or we can build a
phylogenetic tree
so let's first align them
let's uh let us
put this in here
okay and
i'm going to select them select the
results
and alignment
so the process of aligning them
is to introduce the
inserts and deletions based on
this full sequence which is called
global alignment and then once it is
aligned to look for the specific
changes according to these positions
that are highlighted in red
so here as you remember we have
a full sequence that is divided up in
a number of different genes and so if
you
look throughout these positions the
specific positions that
are highlighted are going to be found
within specific genes
right so now we can open this up
and we can actually see the gene
organization
okay and so who can tell me
where is the spike protein on this
genome
does anyone know where would be the
spike protein
okay the spike protein is in here
marked with an s so this is the spike
protein
so right away we can see that some of
the
sequences contain this one mutation
right here
in the spiked protein it seems to be
consistent among several of these
and is not present in some of the other
ones right
so because we have multiple positions
across the whole sequence
and these positions vary by different
samples
sometimes they are consistent and
sometimes they are not
we want to ask the question how are
these sequences
actually related to each other and the
relationship is something that we can
study
by looking at the phylogenetic tree
uh dr aleya um so
you said actually the less mutation and
the spike protein
this is true we have less mutation
correct
well what i mentioned was that some of
the sequences
yeah but generally there are like
maybe actually explanation for why the
majority of the vaccine is
uh does related to the spike proteins
uh because of the like the less mutation
so
it the vaccine will work for a while i
this is what i'm assuming i'm not sure
well okay before we jump to the vaccine
let's first look at the data
right so let's just take a look without
making assumptions
about what is it that we're finding but
our first question
looking at this data is how we can group
these by similarity now we're just
talking about sequence similarity
later on we will talk about how do these
mutations actually
affect the spike protein and maybe we'll
talk about how does it
imply the efficacy of the vaccines but
we'll do that later on
right now if you look the point is that
we have
some consistent mutations that are
repeated
in several of these samples and others
seem to be more random
right and so that is where the
phylogenetic tree can help us
organize this information in a
meaningful way
so if you go back to this page and you
click on a
build phylogenetic tree it will
try to use the sequence similarity
to align the sequences
with a process okay so
as you mentioned they are acquired not
by chance but there's probably some
process behind it
and we can see whether the process
aligns with our understanding of
molecular clock okay so here
we have built our phylogenetic tree and
let's take a look at
what do we find do we find some pattern
that makes sense
or is it something that we don't
understand
okay so we remember we took several
considerations we took
geolocation and we took time
and so here we have california
california louisiana california
louisiana louisiana
right here we have the third month
second third first third third
and here we have 12 11 10
7 7 11. what pattern
seems like more probable looking at this
phylogenetic tree
is it location or is it time
what do you think time problem
yeah it's time i'm sorry i i actually i
i said time
exactly right so we can see that this
clade is all
later months and this plate is all
uh earlier months right
and so what we see is that there's a
separation
into two groups this group
and this group but this group right here
or this sample right here is actually an
outlier so it is thinking that this one
separated from the rest
and then these separated between
themselves
according to this separation now this is
what's called a
simple uh analysis just based sequence
similarity it does not actually
incorporate a real dynamic process
and so to analyze this data in a more
detailed way let us go to the platform
and we'll start taking a look at what
additional information we can get out
from this more detailed analysis
so if you go with me to the server
you can either go with me here or you
can follow along later
we will use this section called
phylogenetic tree
okay and for this analysis what we will
need
is also a reference genome
in genbank format and as a fasta file so
let's see where
we can find these files so that we have
them
ready for our analysis so here i will
type in source
code two
and here you can see that there's a
reference genome it pops up i search for
it here pops up right here
so i can go to this link
and right here if you scroll down
what does this look like is this
nucleotide sequences or amino acid
sequences
that's the sequence in this one amino
acid sequence is excellent yes
so if you find the first one right it
says right here
translation gene id and then translation
and then if you scroll down all the way
to the bottom
you will see that at the bottom you
actually have the full sequence
in nucleotide format so this is called
the genbank format
it's annotated it gives us the full
nucleotide sequence
and it gives us the translation into the
amino acids
with a reference what is this gene id
and so what we can do is we can go to
the top here
and do send to and here you can do a
complete record
file download as a genbank format
so the genbank format is going to
include both nucleotide
and amino acid reference sequence
and also we can just download the file
so i need to reload this
from two file and here
faster format
okay we can call this
source two
now we have the genbank file and the
fasta file
so to perform our analysis we can go
back to here
what type of data are we using for our
analysis
fastq fasta sam bam
or msa
yes what is a sam format sam format is
when reeds are already aligned to the
reference genome
but it contains both the reeds and the
reference genome
we have a consensus genome which is a
faster format so you select fasta
and then you upload the actual
fasta of all of the sequences so upload
files
and i saved it all on downloads
and right here i have all of my
sequences in a single fasta format
now i don't have any groups
so i'll just put in here and here i need
to upload one genbank file for framing
codons so remember trinucleotide
sequences that tell us
what is the translation so i'll add that
the refseq.gb
i have an option to also use
evolutionary time approximations if i
have
sequences that are not annotated with
time
and my question is whether this is an
early or a late or a specific
year i can use references
that i know the collection date for and
that will be included
in the model so here i don't need to do
this
i'm going to skip
and now i can build my pipeline so i'll
click on start
multiple sequence alignment is the first
step
then i need to translate into the amino
acid alignment
sometimes the positions in those codons
change at different rates especially for
viruses and you can see
a reference publication here but in our
case we're going to skip this
and now i have the option to select
multiple phylogenetic
tree formats so i will choose one of
these
and i will use the beast coalescent
model what is the coalescent constant
size
assumes an unknown constant population
size
back through time this model is suitable
whenever it is believed that the
population has remained stable over time
since coalescence is a process directed
backwards in time
in opposite direction of the divergence
it is not advised for speciation
times estimation so it's not really good
for
time estimation let's see what about
birth death process it is
based on the birth death model where
there are both birth rate and death rate
present
this tree prior is most suitable for
trees describing the relationships
between individuals from different
species
since birth death process first
estimates the lineage in
time the last common ancestor and
changes
are measured in the direction of
divergence it is advised to use for
speciation time estimation
it is more sensitive than you'll process
since it has both parameters
so this seems to be like the appropriate
tree right because we
are assuming that there is a birth rate
and there is a death rate
and we know that this is associated with
time
so it seems like this would be the
appropriate method and then we can click
on
end and let's give this a name
and run this pipeline
okay did everyone understand the steps
that we took in this pipeline
yes yes clear but we will apply it later
because
it's really yeah
the time is very limited for us to do it
with you
okay no problem did anyone have any
questions when ian juliana and i am did
you guys have any questions about this
no no that was pr it was pretty clear
the problem that i'm having dr ilia
is that i tried to put my screen
next to your uh presentation
and it's not working so so
that that that's the problem you know
i'm on a laptop so
that's that's that's my problem i have a
big screen
okay but other than that everything is
clear
okay great so once we solve the screen
problem hopefully
we can do this together i really like
doing this together because
if you come across a problem in the
middle
and you get stuck there for a whole week
that means that next time we'll have to
start over
right and so i really recommend
trying to do this maybe after today's
session
i do have the recording and i will share
with all of you
and if you find that you are getting
stuck somewhere
do let me know on slack and i'll be able
to address your question okay
okay okay thank you
okay and another point that i want to
make is that
the same information could be
used on your learn portal
so here under courses there's actually a
whole course
dedicated to the origin and pathogenesis
of source code ii
where you go through all of the steps to
find different genomes
and then to align them and build a
phylogenetic tree
and compare it between different species
and all the way to the interpretation
based on annotation which we will also
do together
but this is a useful resource if you
just want to try and do this on your own
time
now another thing are any of you here
familiar with
coding does anyone code in our
in reality my son just finished a
training for coding
and javascript but he didn't teach me
anything
yet okay
anyone else uh i'm working uh
actually working in python mostly
perfect
well one thing that i want to mention
i'll first talk about
an r because there's a specific exercise
here
but if you look for uh introduction
to bioinformatics i'll just show you
this example
um oh sorry this was an introduction to
data science
introduction to
yeah getting introduction to uh
introduction to bioinformatics
i saw the coding one before i'm not
okay okay so here what you can do
is you can go through a quick tutorial
on how to load these sequences
in r right so all these are sequences
we can load them and make them into an
object
and then you can actually perform
alignment on
two so pairwise alignment and
try it yourself right here so this is a
very short example
you can see but you can actually learn
this code and try this
if you want to acquire also some skills
you'll be able to see that
alignment is a very important part of
many different bioinformatics methods so
you can try and do this right here
learn about how this works and
i believe the same is going to be
available with
python sorry so
python okay so getting started with
bioinformatics and python
right here
so please take a look at this too and
this is a good practice
to kind of get started with things so
um what will we do in our next session
in our next session we will take at the
result of this pipeline
it does not take a long time depending
on how many sequences you've taken
so dr bashir already mentioned he's
interested in egypt
and netherlands you might try different
species
human bat pangolin just find their
scientific names i
didn't find them yet if you want to try
other comparisons with another country
or between
times or between different clades
using the pangolin annotation try those
the objective here is to really make
sure that you can
annotate the results based on
the data that we collected right here
right so right here
we will have to go back and we will see
that
there of different penguin strains that
they come
from different locations that they have
a different collection date
and we can see whether the analysis
matches our expectation
and what can we learn with it we will
actually start looking into the sequence
differences
to try to identify significant mutations
that are going to be important
for all the considerations that we
discussed today with vaccine efficacy
with transmission rate with maybe
lethal outcomes and things like that
thank you so much really perfect
okay so if you do have any questions
again do reach out to me on slack or you
can email me
and i will see you next time this time i
have the recording
so i'm going to share that with you
after this